[Music]
whatever happened to
predictability the milkman the paperboy
evening tv did i get delivered here
somebody tell me
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
the most rewarding part of being
involved with salsa is that 43 years
i've been involved
i got to see salsas growth and also i
got to meet up with so many wonderful
people and that is
my favorite part of it my favorite part
about being in salsa
is getting to connect with and support
my peers by combining creativity and my
passion for linguistics
i think that the most rewarding part of
salsa
for me this year was getting to be able
to create a online community
even though we were on zoom and across
the globe we were still able to connect
and provide a lot of resources which was
super meaningful to me
my favorite part of salsa is getting to
meet more people within the speech
science and linguistics community
my favorite part of salsa is definitely
being able to learn more about the
financial aspects of the club
as well as learning about all the inner
workings and how the ams and all its
different constituencies interact
my favorite part of salsa is by far the
people i've met um i've just made such
incredible friendships
close and it's just been amazing my
favorite part of salsa would have to be
getting to know the professors and staff
of the department and just how the
department runs
you